stephen miller is fully aware of this
that's why they hate him he's a former
senior advisor in the white house he
joins us tonight stephen miller thanks
so much for coming
look i i think for normal people you
know
they tend to be very literal so you know
covets a real disease killed a lot of
people everyone wants to be safe okay
we'll hear you out
refugees americans are big-hearted they
want to help the people who helped us
they want to help in general
you know they want to do the right thing
i don't think a lot of normal americans
of both parties see that there is a
political motive behind these policies
but there clearly is
well what we are witnessing right now
tucker is the greatest bait and switch
of all time
joe biden callously played on america's
sympathies for a small core
of afghans who worked closely in
difficult conditions with american tribs
left all those people nearly in
afghanistan and then in their stead
brought
over a hundred thousand randomly
selected afghan nationals and he is not
bringing them to the united states
through any lawful process or through
any lawful vetting channels and my
sources inside of government
are very clear that most of these
individuals when you run a background
check it comes up blank they're ghosts
nobody knows who they are of course if
they'd worked for the us government when
you take their fingerprints it'd come up
right away but there's no matches
because they didn't work for the
government and nobody knows who they are
but it gets worse
i have also been informed very credibly
that this is the beginning not the end
of the refugee resettlement operation as
we speak the bidet administration is
making preparations through its foreign
consulates and missions
to accept in an open-ended unending way
afghan nationals who leave the country
and apply at any u.s mission around the
globe mostly that will be happening in
pakistan again they will bypass lawful
visa channels and if necessary
abuse and in fact violate a law known as
parole which is meant for very
exceptional case-by-case circumstances
and bring these individuals into the
country with no real vetting and no real
knowledge of who they are
but more important than all of this
tucker is common sense if you bring in
several provinces worth of individuals
from afghanistan you will replicate the
conditions in afghanistan here in the
united states of america and all the
horse that entails
which is why i think martha's vineyard
is a perfect place for them to go are
the islands big enough for a hundred
thousand afghan refugees and if the
people on that island can afford to help
they say they care
every single afghan refugee should be
moved to martha's vineyard open their
homes their clubs open their private
schools when they're private dinner
clubs all of it amen tonight stephen
miller i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else